monsieur des images de la zone de
recherche en Islande révèlent que des
matériaux ont refait surface continuez
il y a 80 % de chance qu'il s'agisse de
l'objet que nous
recherchons il est temps de passer à la
phase
une méfiez-vous de ces gens ils vont
vous tuer tous les
deux tu m'entends ouais tu es où là
juste à l'ISE
de tu m'ites même pas toujours en
de c'est moi je voulais seulement dire
que je te trouve toujoursi
lour c'est quoi ce
délire
écoutezmiement
Nère que tu fais pied nu rentre à
l'intérieury
ça ques sont les nouvelles les
recherchpcune trace de Naé je veux
savoir tout ce qu'il y a à savoir à
propos de chrean ce
professeur tu sais qui à propos d'un
avion de l'armé na qui s'est écrasé dans
la région de là tu parles de l'opération
Napoléon c'est ça apparemment il s'agit
d'un secret qui pourrait changer le
cours de
l'histoire
mon père m'a fait promettre de ne jamais
chercher cet avion si on ne voulait pas
mourir je n'ai pas envie de plaisanter
s'il y a quelque chose ici mes hommes
trouveront la police est à la recherche
de
chemm d'ination Surp en jusqu ce qu'on
trouve la
fem bord de l'avion c'est
possible on a commencé à trouver des
choses un groupe de personnes qui
vivaient dans l'ombre on ne s'en ira pas
d'ici sans
Napoléon
[Musique]